bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment est-ce que
vous expliquer cette situation comment
les plus riches sont-ils parvenus à
maintenir leur fortune et parfois même à
s'enrichir
disons les plus riches ont bénéficié de
la bonne tenue de la bourse s'est donc
tenue provient du fait que les banques
centrales un peu partout maintiennent
des taux d'intérêt très faibles et ont
que ça permet à la bourse de monter il
ya des spéculateurs ou des industriels
qui emprunte à taux zéro pour investir
en bourse et d'autre part on a des
secteurs qui ont dù mais pendant la
crise en particulier les secteurs liés à
l'informatique à internet aussi au camp
sa tesla au véhicule et électriques donc
d'un logo ces chefs d'entreprise qui ont
une fortune professionnelle ont
bénéficié de la situation est alors
pourquoi est-ce que ça pose problème que
les fortunes des plus riches ne se soit
pas effondré ils ont ça ne pose pas
problème les fortunes des plus riches
s'étaient effondrés en mars ils se sont
repris depuis
ce qui pose problème c'est que d'un côté
on peut penser que partie de la bourse
de la pose de la bourse c'est une bulle
financière donc ça risque de s'effondrer
et d'autre part compte tenu des besoins
particules pour les plus pauvres
on peut se dire après tout pourquoi ne
pas détourner une partie de cette
richesse vers les plus pauvres ou vers
les besoins en matière de santé ou de
transition écologique et justement fort
de ce constat oxfam comme d'autres
appellent à taxer les plus riches pour
combattre les inégalités quel est votre
regard sur ce point nous savons que
l'échelle mondiale il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire il faut aider les pays
les plus pauvres il faut aider les
pauvres dans les pays riches
on constate que durant ces dernières
années
la financiarisation a fait que
et la mondialisation a fait fortune
immense se sont instaurés aussi bien
dans les pays occidentaux que en chine
en russie dans un certain nombre de cas
ces fortunes ne sont pas justifiées par
l'apport que des chefs d'entreprise
aurait fait à l'humanité et donc qu'il
est légitime que l'on réfléchisse à les
taxer à l'échelle européenne ou à
l'échelle mondiale légitime que une
partie des profits des grandes sociétés
multinationales soient taxés pour
financer
comme j'ai déjà dit la transition
écologique ou les dépenses de santé et
en france comment s'établit la fiscalité
à des plus riches
la particularité des françaises c'est
que grosso modo on a un système qui est
protecteur pour les plus pauvres on a le
rsa on a le minimum vieillesse on a on a
le chômage partiel mais en même temps on
n'a pas le gouvernement les
gouvernements macro ont réduit la
fiscalité sur les plus riches avec la
suppression de l'isf avec le fait que
les plus riches que les revenus que les
revenus financiers ne sont plus soumis à
la peau sont revenus avec la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation qui quand même
profitent aux plus riches et donc sa
part peut dire dans le mauvais sens en
même temps n'a pas pris à l'échelle
européenne des mesures fortes pour
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale des
grandes sociétés multinationales et donc
ils ont encore du pain sur la planche
pour taxer les grandes entreprises
multinationales et les plus riches
la pandémie a entraîné la perte de
quelque 255 millions d'emplois dans le
monde l'année dernière selon à
l'organisation internationale du travail
est ce que vous vous attendez à une
vague de paupérisation sur l'ensemble de
la planète
vous savez ya pas de miracle à la
production a chuté d'environ 5% à
l'échelle mondiale peut être même plus
on va pas se rétablir en 2021 dans sont
restés à un niveau très faible donc
naturellement ça va peser sur l'ensemble
des populations en particulier
naturellement sur les pays les plus
pauvres il n'y a pas de système de
protection sociale il n'y a pas
d'assurance maladie universelle et où
une partie de l'emploi et de l'emploi
informel il donc naturellement d'emplois
formels n'est absolument pas couverts
dans ce genre de situation donc il faut
on va avoir besoin d'aider ces pays
sachant quand même que jusqu'à présent
l'afrique et l'asie peuplé et sont
relativement épargnés par la pandémie
mais ça peut venir très vite et donc il
faut dégager à l'échelle mondiale et des
capacités pour aider ce pays est aussi
bientôt pour les vacciner merci beaucoup
pour votre regard henri sterdyniak
économiste à l'ouest c'est eux et
cofondateur des économistes atterrés